[Musique]
moi je pense que healy a effectivement
il faut se sortir du carcan des des 35
heures la question du temps de travail
devra se poser mais dans un cadre de
dialogue social et dans l'entreprise ou
dans les branches lorsqu'on a on est sur
de petites entreprises ça ne peut pas
être décidé par les traits valeur
travail est une valeur essentielle qu'on
ne peut pas balayer d'un revers de la
main mais elle est essentielle à deux
conditions
d'abord qu'elle soit reconnaissante et
rémunérés évidemment que hallyday l'idée
de travailler 37 heures pour être payées
ça suffit c'est terminé et donc
d'ailleurs c'est pas l'idée que la
droite républicaine nous portons
aujourd'hui il faut que cet effort il
est un sens si deux mais nous demandons
à les travailleurs à des ouvriers de
travailler pour relocaliser notre
industrie dans le pays alors ça aura du
sens qu'il faut trouver un moyen pour
transformer le chômage partiel je pense
en incitations au travail
[Musique]
on a reproché au gouvernement d'avoir
disons pour être prudents les des contre
vérités sur les masques sur les tests
d'avoir pris beaucoup de retard ceci
étant il était important de sortir du et
du confinement et que l'économie puisse
puisse redémarrer donc on voit bien les
difficultés que ça peut présenter dans
les écoles dans les transports mais ceci
étant il fallait sortir du confinement à
partir du moment où les conditions
sanitaires le permettait nous avons fait
des propositions 50 propositions pour un
déconfinement sur éclair et
malheureusement nous n'avons pas
toujours été entendu et je le regrette
assurer une sortie du confinement qui
puisse permettre à la fois de relever ce
défi sanitaire et urgences majeures
aussi de relancer l'économie pour moi
aller confinement va pas assez vite en a
encore les deux pieds sur le frein et je
pense qu'il faut accélérer l
déconfinement c'est une question de de
survie également économique l'économie
comme l'école ne peuvent pas être
indéfiniment confiné tant qu'on n'a pas
de vaccin de toute façon il faut prendre
des mesures transitoires
[Musique]
est ce qu'on est capable de donner des
masques à toute la population
j'observe que la population et la
plupart du temps désormais dotées de
masques mais ce n'est pas l'état qui
leur a donné les collectivités
territoriales et les maires en
particulier ont pallier l'insuffisance
de de l'état s'il y avait des masques
périmés bien sûr qu'il fallait les
détruire mais pourquoi on a pas
renouveler le stock après les avoir
détruit c'est là la question
[Musique]